you've had some iconic roles there's one
it's probably one of the ones that you
probably get recognized the most for
especially among young people and that
would be the waterboy yeah I'm curious
about that because I'm told I'm told
that that was a role you almost turn
down without even reading it is that
true well I read the first 12 pages I
read the first I was in my bed and I
read the first 12 pages and I thought oh
this is a piece of [ __ ] and I always
keep a trash can right by my bed just
for all those scrimp yeah you know and
so I threw it away and my niece who
works for me she came and he says what
is this I said oh I'm stupid script they
sent me and she pulled it out and she
said and I said who is that she said
don't you know the Hanukkah song yeah so
she made me do the movie
[Laughter]
he's right
so my son we had so much fun it was a
really fun movie and you and probably a
part that you get stopped for yeah no
they don't recognize me for that about
you mean when they see ya yeah that's
right we started out saying yeah yeah we
have to get our story straight
no no you don't recognize me at all
that's not true yeah it is it's great
you like that yeah cuz they they're
they're like it takes them a while yeah
and then I can be gone are you stealing
stuff what are you doing
and God